farid fernandez ancien diplomate
vénézuélien et consultants fary de
fernandez merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors nicolás
maduro a donc donné ce lundi 72 heures à
la chef de la délégation de l'union
européenne pour quitter le venezuela
comment analyser cette décision
la première chose à dire c'est que on a
une réaction ici du gouvernement
vénézuélien
face à ceux qui l'interprètent comme une
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
du venezuela
et là on peut voir effectivement mettre
en lumière l'échec de sa stratégie qui
vise à face à une démocratie venezuela
qui fonctionne mal du fait à la fois des
tensions internes mais aussi des
pressions externes depuis les etats-unis
principalement on voit l'union
européenne qui depuis des années avec un
train de retard effectivement
constamment derrière les états unis mais
qui suit cette stratégie de pressions
externes contre le venezuela à travers
des sanctions très dures mais qui ne qui
n'atteignent pas leur objectif le il n'y
a pas de progrès dans les négociations
entre les deux camps venezuela
il n'y a pas d'effet positif de ces
sanctions pour la démocratie
vénézuélienne où les pistes pour que la
société parisienne se pacifie et que
chaque fraction de cette société puisse
puisse estimer légitimement représentés
mais quel est l'intérêt au fond pour
l'union européenne
je n'en vois aucun personnellement cette
stratégie en plus de sanctionner alors
il y a cette liste est diverse 1 mais il
y à des personnes dans cette liste qui
sont ces individus qui sont sanctionnés
simplement pour avoir fait de la
politique au venezuela
quand on voit que le président alors
d'une des compliqué désolé il ya
plusieurs organes qui prétendent
représenter le pouvoir législatif et
mais il y à une assemblée nationale qui
est présidée par un député qui s'appelle
louise parra qui a été sanctionnée face
qu'il a effectivement pris le pouvoir
dans cette assemblée nationale en
janvier face à monsieur guido qui est
reconnu par l'union européenne comme le
président de
le national en exercice et président
intérimaire du venezuela
ce qui pose la question effectivement de
savoir pourquoi est ce que par exemple
cette personne est sanctionné est ce
qu'elle est sanctionné parce qu'elle
fait de la politique et qu'elle cherche
effectivement à part le jeu des
alliances parlementaires leur
effectivement c'est un petit peu cocasse
on peut dire que le la démocratie
brésilienne est dysfonctionnel
mais cela étant ce n'est pas le rôle de
l'union européenne à mon sens de
sanctionner des personnes parce qu'elles
font de la politique au venezuela il ne
s'agit pas ici de vols violations
flagrantes des droits de l'homme
il s'agit de l'exercice par le parti
politique par les partis politiques de
la politique aux anatomies nationale
alors en tout cas l'union européenne a
menacé prendre des mesures de
réciprocité qu'est ce que risque
aujourd'hui concrètement caracas alors
le gouvernement maduro a décidé de donc
d'expulser la représentant de l'union
européenne au venezuela dans la
diplomatie ce qu'on appelle la
réciprocité puisse cesser ce que c'est
ce dont menace la l'union européenne
maintenant face à c est ça cette
décision du gouvernement m'a d'euros la
réciprocité serait d'expulser les
représentants diplomatiques dont les
ambassadeurs du venezuela auprès de
l'union européenne et aux prêts et
éventuellement de certains de ces et de
ses états membres
moi personnellement j'ai vécu de très
près les les les processus de
négociation qui sous-tendent adoption de
ces sanctions
elles sont adoptées par unanimité
il faut la lignée de limiter des de tous
les états membres
on verra maintenant au sein de l'union
européenne s'il ya des pays
peut-être qu'ils essaient quittance d'un
de modérer la poule à la position d'une
européenne peut être d'arriver à apaiser
les tensions actuelles
honnêtement je n'en vois pas vraiment le
le
je ne crois pas que ce soit un scénario
possible je pense qu'on va vers une
ligne dure
c'est celle qui gagne au sein de l'union
européenne depuis des années avec
effectivement comme je disais tout à
l'heure
cette tentative de de ne pas avoir une
politique autonome une politique qui
favorise la négociation au venezuela
mais une politique qui suit le sel qui
est celle qui est adoptée aux états unis
à washington
si beaucoup farid fernandez veut d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant et ancien diplomate